hello everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel and also welcome to
another
exciting video from simply learn based
on java games
yes you heard me right games this
particular video is based on
the interview questions asking some of
the most popular mnc companies such as
amazon google and ibm yes the question
about gaming is an integral part of
interview questions from the top mnc
companies to test the object oriented
programming skills of a developer
now there are not a lot of games that we
will be discussing today
there are three most frequently asked
gaming questions
that are the snake game parcel game and
the ping pong game
so we have open source this particular
code from google and github
and we have also placed the links in the
description box below and along with
that
and also i have personally made a
document of all the codes used in this
particular video for you so that you can
have access to it
and write the code in your own local
system so the first game that we will be
discussing today is the snake game
so this particular snake game is most
frequently asked in the top mnc company
such as amazon and flipkart
now let's get into the eclipse window
and try to execute the code
so now we are in the eclipse window and
on my screen you can see a code based on
the simple snake
so basically this particular snake game
on my screen has the snake
trees and its directions based on the
keystroke you give
that is right left up down etc and the
start game option
and stop the game option like if you
want to pause it in the middle
and after that the energy used treats
eaten moving snake
grow snake etc etc so now we'll try to
start this game and see how it functions
yeah there you go you can see that the
program got started and the output is on
my screen
so you just need to click to start so
there you go the snake is
around here
it's actually fun to play
so that's how you program it and don't
worry about the code the open source
github link for this particular code is
placed in the description box below
and this particular quote is also
written as a text document
and that text document is also attached
in the description box below
now we will move ahead with our next
game
so the next game is the puzzle game
so this particular game is asked and
some of the popular mnc companies
like google now let's look into the code
which is really simple and try to
execute this on
the eclipse so now we are back on the
eclipse
so you can see on my screen we have the
code for the alphabet puzzle game that
we are going to execute
so basically this particular alphabet is
going to have
three rows and three columns so in total
we'll be having
nine cells out of which eight cells will
be occupied
so one particular cell which is a nine
cell will be empty for the motions
now we have a b c d e f g and
h and one empty space which is a block b
eight
now let's try to execute this code and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
puzzle game on my screen right now
so you can see it's almost already
arranged
luck by chance maybe so just let's click
the on the edge
so now you can see that we have won the
particular game and
it is in the ordered sequence that is a
b c d e f
g and h since we have done the
arrangement proper
the game shows we have one
congratulations you won
now let's just press ok and let's
continue with our
next game so the third game that we will
be discussing today will be
about the ping pong game
so this particular ping-pong game is
asked in some of the famous mnc
companies
like ibm now let's try to execute this
particular code on the eclipse window
and see the artwork
now we are back on the eclipse window so
this particular game will have three
classes that has
the ball class which is the movement of
the ball
next we have the paddle which is all
about the boat and the paddles that we
play with
and next the pog this particular class
is all about
how the code runs or how the game runs
now let's try to execute this particular
program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
pawn game over here
yeah so that's how you play it
please don't worry about the codes we
have the open source github links for
all the games we have used in the
description box below
along with that we have also placed a
text document of all the codes used in
this particular video
you can have access to it and try to
execute that code in your local system
so with that we have come to an end of
this particular video on java games
so the gaming type of questions are
basically asked from the popular mnc
companies
to test the object-oriented programming
skills of the developer if you have any
queries about the quotes covered in this
particular video please ask away in the
comment section below
our team of experts will be happy to
solve your queries and thank you for
watching
stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here